from The Daily Mail check this out San
Francisco Whole Foods made more than 560
emergency calls over 13 months after
rampant drug use in the restrooms people
defecating on the floor and violence
towards staff and that's all to all 250
shopping baskets were stolen all of them
that's impressive who lives in this
place that's yeah so
um it's interesting because no not me of
course not well I know that in
California right if it's under a
thousand dollars worth of merchandise
you can't be arrested but this is Whole
Foods so if someone steals a celery
stick you can call it please that's why
they made all these reports I mean San
Francisco is where the targets are
locking everything up it's where all the
Walgreens and CVS's are closing this is
not it's exactly what we're talking
about in Portland this is not a
sustainable City for businesses and when
the businesses leave everything else
will collapse along with it well in
ideologues want this because they
believe they're going to be able to
create something new From the Ashes
to destroy ideologues also aren't
capable of seeing flaws in their world
view when they manifest themselves in
the real world oftentimes but it's so
disheartening how your average person is
struggling to see some of this I mean
just your average liberal how can you
vote for the party that turned Chicago
into Chicago that turns New York and New
York that turns San Francisco and what
San Francisco is that has kept Detroit
like Detroit how could you vote for that
what do you want America to be more like
do you want America to be more like
Texas like Florida like all the places
people are leaving your states to go to
right or do you want America to be more
like the states that these this party is
ruined I mean do you feel like the
youngest generation or maybe you know
whatever generation is old enough to run
for mayors of cities are producing
another uh Rudy Giuliani so to speak
like someone who is willing to address
the challenges or do we feel like we
have uh lost the era of a conservative
mayor in a major metropolitan area and
look it's possible for there to be some
kind of political backlash in those
areas I could see it happening but who
knows they might be too far gone I'm
kind of excited
you know because it's just like you know
why Tim Tammy's like Civil War I'm
talking about that I'm talking about
these people voted for it they got
exactly what they wanted and I I'm happy
for them I'm like this is fantastic we
now get to see what happens under
Democrat policy and then let the
experiment play out and you know what
maybe this is the molting phase and all
of these policies result in Utopia
exactly
literally Burns to the ground because
antifa's firebombing these buildings and
we've left a long time ago I don't think
I think the division has reached such a
point like you know right versus left
ideologically wise is it doesn't matter
what policies are pushed through for the
left or how many cities get burned down
how many businesses shut down how bad
the economy is they're going to keep
voting the same way because it's US
versus them they're the racists they're
this they're that and the US versus them
politics has just reached a point it's
like the hairy Sisson kid right that's
been going viral recently that the
right's kind of been elevating it's like
that show he literally does not care and
doesn't really know what the effect
policies has he knows that it's not good
and that Republican policies are better
but it doesn't no no I don't think he
knows anything I think he just knows
that it's making him famous yeah well
he's making him money too he's getting
paid well also you have to consider that
people who vote Democrat are notoriously
low information voters it's not to say
you don't have any people who have a lot
of information to vote Democrat and it's
not to say you don't have any people who
are low information and vote Republican
but Democrats know that the moral
information people vote the better off
their political party is going to be
which is why you always see these get
out and vote ad campaigns where they
have some celebrity who's almost always
a Democrat stand in front of a camera
and tell television audiences that they
need to go fulfill their civic duty and
vote now why would you want people who
only vote because a celebrity tells them
to to vote because you need people who
have no idea what they're talking about
out there voting no idea what they're
voting on everyone wants to talk all day
long about your civic duty to
participate in the electoral process no
one ever talks about the civic duty to
know about the issues that you're voting
on why is it better to have people who
haven't researched any of this in voting
booths how on Earth could you make that
argument unless you were doing so
cynically because you know that those
people will vote for your political
party because low information people
always do I think it's the most
discouraging thing ever to understand
that these kinds of people that are very
low information and just vote because
they see a celebrity on TV and it tells
them to do it or they need to uphold
democracy their vote matters just as
much as yours so that's very just like
it's black pilling you know I try to be
as white pill as possible it's like most
people in this country should not be
able to vote there should be simple you
know requirements at least a litmus test
of hey do you actually know how politics
Works do you know what policy is and it
can be as simple as like how many
members of Congress are yeah it doesn't
need to be Senator games or
what do you think about the issue that
you're voting on what do you like about
this candidate or dislike about this
other candidate do you have any idea
what this is you know are you like the
letter next to their name Community or
your Society I mean that's one of the
things that gets to meet people who are
like I'm gonna vote for this person even
though I don't care what happens to
everyone else like if you hate America
and you're participating in our
government system just because you want
to see it fall apart that's that's
chaotic evil uh the other thing I was
gonna say is it's celebrities but also
next gen America that uh I think
Bloomberg started it it's a non-profit
they had a whole thing where they uh
reached out to people on dating apps and
they were like hey are you going to the
polls like you should do this and they
they Market it as a get out the vote
campaign for everybody but obviously
it's a completely that is so
manipulative yeah and like the thing is
conservatives wouldn't do this it is
effective it apparently it does generate
some voters you should only be allowed
to vote if you know the 15th president
was
oh
everyone in the room is I I think you
should only be able to vote if you have
some kind of state by the way I would
eliminate myself from this right I think
that you have to I would say either own
property or have children or something
like that yeah maybe my own property
yeah I I I think it's I think the wild
that people who are effective too no I I
hear you that's that's my point and
again that would eliminate me but I
don't understand why a person who
doesn't have any tangible stake in the
future in that way would be able to vote
I would I would also say clergy I guess
people who are making some real
legitimate sacrifice for society and
I've talked to people who say like well
what if you didn't you know military
members and then you can't like maybe
you're not owning land but you are
contributing or like people who do kind
of Americorps type volunteer work like
there are ways that we could measure
whether you're basically your Civic
engagement in this country uh but I do
think that we have a whole generation of
people who feel intense apathy and anger
towards everything about America and
therefore when they vote they don't cast
their vote thinking about what the
longevity for themselves their children
their neighbors is they think about well
what can serve me best for right now
because basically I'm I think this ship
is going down and I don't really care
well I mean they should ask questions
like before you can vote answer one
question about U.S Civics how many
presidents are there and then when
they're like most people wouldn't even
know right they'd be you've seen the
street videos
are there right now yeah uh into three
seven I saw one the other side that
exact question and they're like uh
58 presidents
what that that's what you see these men
on the street all that does is there's
gonna be a lot of people are gonna be
like one what do you mean you're like no
no that's fine you go vote no don't
worry about it and the people who don't
know it's like you you probably should
not be voting you can there's a cookie
over there I just I don't know how
somebody that's an idea you get a table
with free cookies and when someone comes
up and say you can vote right now or
free cookie
you can't vote yeah you bribe them
against voting well it's just like
someone's willing to accept that bribe
they should be voting be voting if they
don't know what they're if they would
rather eat a cookie than vote they
probably shouldn't it's like it's like
the opposite like the inverse of what
they did with the vaccines is like oh
hey you get a free you know big Whopper
and a cookie if you get this vaccine
remember that video of uh what's his
face
I don't know like he also I don't know
how to put this but he ate them weirdly
correct you have like never seen someone
eat french fries incorrectly like he was
an alien and it was his first time yeah
you're like all right so we're really
we're really incentivizing healthy
living yeah
well back to the um old Starship
Troopers there well I was talking with
Vivek Rama Swami about it and the idea
was kind of like when you sign up for
Selective Service man or woman you both
have to do it as soon as you do you get
your voter card and if you don't sign up
you don't have to nobody's forced to do
it but you don't get you don't get your
voter card unless you don't yeah
there has to be some kind of metric for
this I mean look
I don't know you can make arguments from
consequence you can make the argument
that's it right there how many how many
women would be like Einstein up for the
draft and you buy well then you don't
vote how many men would be like I ain't
sign up for the draft but then you don't
vote my so well Men actually do have to
sign up for the draft so the point he
was married I get what you're saying men
and women both have to sign up if they
want to vote but you don't have to sign
up yeah that's a good idea I I think if
you can make arguments from consequence
for for democracy to varying you know
Effectiveness but I have yet to hear a
convincing argument that everyone's
opinion is equally worth taking into
consideration when it comes to how our
government is run I I no one's been able
to make an argument for that
that makes any amount of sense other
than it's mean not to it would be really
mean it's all right you don't want bad
thing do you Sheamus I don't want bad
things I mean right now you want I think
he want bad thing that's the Democratic
policy that's literally it is you want
bad thing it's okay well so you're
telling me that someone who has
contributed massively has spent their
life sacrificing his built things has
brought life into the world as many
children all of the things that a
healthy Society should value has just as
much of a say in how our government is
run as someone who has contributed
absolutely nothing and I'm not even
saying someone who hasn't contributed
anything because they've lived badly I'm
even talking about teenagers in 18 year
old why should an 18 year old be able to
vote what does an 18 year old know
nothing nothing
and there are people who want to push
the voting age to 16. the voters that
well they used to know things but even
back then back when they knew things the
voting age was 21.
it got pushed back to 18 and that was
back when 18 year olds had been living
on their own for two years or taking
care of themselves as adults for at
least two years and even then we said
you're not able to vote you just don't
know enough and now you're dependent
upon your parents until you're early to
mid-20s and we let 18 year olds vote
it's insane have you ever yeah we're
going backwards on that front exactly
and people are going I think 16 year
olds should be able to vote are you out
of your mind have you but you know why
low information voters thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time